[Applause]
it takes you away penultimate episode
for series 11 of Doctor Who and this is
it's what's different um I think the
main thing I want to be clear right off
is I do think I like it
overall and if nothing else even if it
doesn't totally come together I admire
the scope and ambition of it what it
isn't is it isn't dull and it isn't
lacking in imagination so like I I think
the worst thing a Doctor Who episode
could be is boring so as long as it is
still interesting it's not a total
failure to me and I do find this
interesting I think if there's an issue
it's the fact that it's some conflicting
interesting things going on as it kind
of stumbles its way along I do find this
episode oddly endearing though I'll try
and hold off on the flat-out spoilers I
will get to them though some of the like
if you want the most spoiler for you get
that's it like I'm not entirely sure it
works but I still kind of like it but
that might just because I'm weird and my
tastes are weird so yeah take that as
the very bizarre jumbled kind of almost
endorsement that I guess it is so first
off the atmosphere at the front end
really impressive there was a great sort
of creepiness to it you know just just
starting out seeing the house all
boarded up it had the feel that I got
off episodes like the empty child just
sort of that feeling of okay what's
going on um and then the mirror was are
just a really cool effect like looking
in this mirror like wait what where are
we and I do gotta love that Ryan goes we
know if we were bad
right because as silly as that sounds
like that probably would have been my
first thought to like I'm not a vampire
right I don't think I'm a vampire so all
of that and then it goes into like this
whole other section in the in the anti
zone which feels and in a way feels
different but like a kind of oddly
connect so like I can break this whole
thing into three fairly distinct chunks
yet it kind of oddly for me at least
flows decently from one chunk to the
next so we've got our are scary tense
almost horror esque setup we've got the
segment in the ante zone which is
different which feels it from that but
is kind of connected by the sense of
tension and then but sort of the newness
of the what is going on where are we
sort of then connects us to the the tail
end of it in the sensing universe and
I'm just getting into spoilers at this
point so if you haven't already checked
out you might want to do that if you
haven't seen the thing I'm assuming you
have so oh there is like thin threads
connect the segment about a they are
kind of tenuous connections I don't know
man this one's just weird
but coming back to the anti zone I like
the general it's saved by the by the guy
that they encounter there because the
general feel of you know oh it's a cave
a new killer moths like actually I
don'ts call for the killer moths I think
the idea of a mock that ignores clothes
it eats flesh is actually kind of like
just a cool very simple concept but like
if it was just the cave in the moth I'm
like I I would consider a filler but I
liked the guy who's there I like him a
lot I like he reminded me a lot of Star
Trek style alien which is that he very
clearly approaches everything from a
different mindset from how people do so
like to make the Star Trek comparison
how the Ferengi approach everything from
the angle of what's the profit how the
Vulcans approach everything from what's
most logical how the Klingons approach
everything from what is the most
honorable warrior way to do this this
guy approaches
thing from a perspective of food and
I've seen that go wrong I've seen the
two doctors but so it's kind of cool to
almost feel like it's revisiting that
idea that didn't work back go back in
the day but sort of coming at it from an
angle like I kind of like hanging around
this guy yeah the way he describes
anything he likes is delicious and yeah
it's I liked him I liked his presence
and he live IND up that middle segment
that otherwise could've been a real drag
on the whole episode and then we get
into the last section which is very like
for lack of a better comparison it
reminded me of a wrinkle in time I'm not
just the movie with a book and that sort
of feel of that more sort of pseudo
spiritual new agey approach to science
fiction and the idea of a sentient
universe that just wants to connect and
doesn't want to be alone it has that
more you know explore the universe
through the pathways of your mind kind
of feel and approach to sci-fi witch
doctor who doesn't do a ton of but it's
a thing that again I kind of grew up
with that kind of you know seventies
sixties new agey sci-fi kind of stuff so
I kinda I have an affinity for it so
again like I'm coming away going I think
I like this episode but I totally get
why most people might not are at best
they're gonna be really confused by it
but for some reason it just happened to
like tick off the boxes that worked for
me personally and I think each second
segment is well done in and of itself
and the Frog boy like I was really
tempted as my opening kind of gag on
this to pull a quote from the good place
but I thought it was too much of a
spoiler and B it was a reference not
enough people get but I just I couldn't
help think of the doorman from a good
place like yeah it's a frog I like frogs
I'm a frog guy
it's like but it again is
like okay that's weird but it's also
very upfront with the fact that like
yeah this is supposed to be weird this
is not supposed to be like the universe
is a frog well no of course that makes
no sense that's the point it makes no
sense go with it and I can't I think
it's just because that that kind of
you're gonna see something that these
are pieces that don't fit together but
this is the best way your brain can make
sense of it because the universe is too
grand and crazy to ever make for you to
ever make total sense out of which is
actually kind of how I think in general
like my general approach to life is that
look I'm gonna I'm I'm not gonna throw
my hands and go it's not worth trying to
figure anything out but I know I'm never
gonna figure all this stuff out like I
can't like I'm incapable of so I always
have an affinity for the the concept of
okay now it's not really this but this
is how you're perceiving it because this
is the best you're ever going to
understand it and it kind of again it
kind of hit me on that vibe the whole
tail end section was the Frog and I kind
of like the doctors reaction to it a
kind of melancholy of uh yeah that was
never gonna work but but if a shame that
um and Jodie Whittaker was was good in
this I I'm I'm still not sure that I've
had my moment like the moment of that's
the doctor but again I'm not gonna go
like and that means she's no good in the
part because again looking back on it I
didn't really have it for Capaldi for
his entire first series and by the time
he was done I loved Capaldi so you know
I I'm not holding that against the show
but like I'm I'm definitely on board
with her at this point she did I haven't
had that mobile room like that's the
doctor like 100% but I I'm and
definitely not going like that's not the
doctor like no it is I'm just waiting
for like my moment to like go yes and I
haven't quite had it yet but I'm
enjoying her Bryan and Graham they're
doing a good job of like they've done a
good job over the course of this series
building their relationship even across
some of the episodes that I did like I
think that's I mean I'll talk about some
of this stuff later when I do a series
11 wrap-up but I think
the the folk the focus on injured
character relationships has been
well-handled possibly at the expense of
other stuff but that's been well handled
I also think like I feel like him can
finally nailed down why yaz isn't
working for me
for the most part because again she's
not bad in this episode but something
that happened twice in this episode that
made me realize oh that's why she
doesn't work for me is they have to keep
stopping and pausing to single out why
she's good and why she should be there
because they don't need to do that with
Ryan and Graham because well Graham's
just adorable and lovable he's carrying
a sandwich just in case for crying out
loud and then Ryan has his own emotional
arc and his growth and his through line
in his relationship with Graham which
we're getting to just watch build and
develop so that justifies itself right
there yes they keep having to go out of
their way to justify so like when Ryan
points out you were really good with
that kid and you know yeah it's like
well you know I've had training it you
know as a police officer I had to stop
and go what she really good with a kid
oh I guess she was but I didn't notice
cuz there was way more interesting kind
of organic stuff going on and the show
and I feel like they realize that in the
show goes out of its way to go hey did
you notice she was good at that and I'm
like okay I guess it's a little fresh a
you had to point it out and then they
kind of did it again with her being like
can't you reverse the polarity or
something I'm like that's totally
something the doctor would have normally
thought of on her own but they gave it
to yaz again it feels like they they
have to do a lot of extra legwork to try
and justify a adds and and her value
there and that's not me saying that she
is devoid of value but they have to
highlight it every single time where
they don't have to do that with the Ryan
and Graham because it feels much more
just growing out of their interaction
that we see their value to the narrative
if not necessarily to inherently to the
doctor so I thought I think I think I
finally nailed down my issues with the
ads in basically every episode except
the demon of the Punjab other than that
of the young girl who was blind she was
good like my inclination booed I didn't
look this up Isis
she probably really is blind because if
she's not the ability to unfocus her
eyes is astounding I suspect she
probably actually is blind and and she
did a good job
the there was just again this is a weird
episode and from any objective stance
I'm not sure it works like especially
given where it ends versus where it
begins and again they gave a very dumb
name to an alien phenomena well as its
ally attracts like I can't I can't
remember these things are fade from my
mind
whoever's picking the names whether it's
Chibnall or if it's a it's a like the
writers were collectively voting on
options they like it would have been
better to just not name the thing but
I'm yeah I find this one oddly endear
like maybe if I were to come but like
this is not a comparison of how the
episode is at all but like in comparison
for me is like how I enjoy robot of
robots of Sherwood quite a bit but I
know a lot of other people don't and I
kind of get why but like it just happens
to hit specific things that work for me
and I feel this kind of in the same way
like okay I would not be surprised if
like a bunch of people are either
confused by this episode or they're like
they hate it I like it but it just
happens to scratch weird itches for me
and again what I will defend about is
even if it doesn't connect with you like
it's not unimaginative and it's not
boring it's it swings for the fences
whether or not you think it managed to
connect or not that's another thing but
I surprised liking the more than I think
once it ended I was like I don't know
what to make of that but the more I
think about it and now talking about it
like no I actually I did like that it's
weird and it's yeah it's weird and wonky
but I like it okay so ho
it takes you away what are your thoughts
I'll be really curious hear people's
thoughts on this one cuz I get my
suspicions is I will probably
get a lot more than most other people
but love to find out what the case
actually is whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it a whole bunch of
stuff you can do because there's buttons
and there's links including one to my
patreon if you want to support me in
that fashion if you don't don't worry
about it other links you can check out
don't want to check those out don't have
to worry about that either I cuz at the
end of the day folks
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]